monday baseball from tropicana field in
saint petersburg the final regular
season game of 2020 between the rays and
the jays this year the script has been
the same toronto wins game one of the
series tampa bay wins the rest today a
chance to write a successful final
chapter in this the 30th game of a 60
game regular season that currently has
tampa bay one game up in the american
league east well it for blake snell and
with the pitch count you can see the
build up slow at first and then it
started to gather steam he got to 92
pitches his last timeout and that really
means at this point he is turned loose
blake snell will be out there pitching
as long as he is effective viggio at the
plate and we're all set to play baseball
3-2 again
and he got him looking there how about
that
he comes back with a little breaking
ball together and he put it in a spot
that you're not expecting you know i
mean left on left curveball you're not
thinking inside corner
and so that's why you just don't end up
pulling the trigger and swinging here's
lourdes goriel moved up into the cleanup
spot today
and he is out on
and
strike
exactly
what he needed right there he had him
out in front well there's a reason that
blake snell has the highest chase rate
in major league baseball a lot of it has
to do with that pitch dana rock will
make his fifth start of the season here
this afternoon second time he will face
the tampa bay rays so laos aboard and
here's yandy diaz
he lets it go
a shovel for one and on to first double
play nicely done from biggio to espinal
into back to the bag they retire diaz
and the inning is over one another count
to danny jansen
and the center field right center not
all that deep caremeyer is there
stretching out to make the grab well
jansen trying to drop one in there
and keermire
prevented him from picking up the base
hit nicely done two up two down panico
two and a ground ball up the middle
backhanded nice stop wendell
and another outstanding defensive play
reigns at that inning putting on a show
defensively for now nobody owned no
score ray's looking for their first hit
here is yoshitsugo
here's a long one off the bat
that's well tagged and gonna be gone
home run
number four
[Music]
and the rays break out in front zugo
turns on that 1-0 pitch here's willy
adams
starting to stop by wendell and the
ball line down the left field line into
the corner by adamus wendell's gonna
round third head to the plate relay
throw gonna be close he is out at the
plate
and into third goes adamus wendell
trying to score from first cut down here
meyer with two outs and a runner with
third
chops it right side
and a race for the bay he is safe
save for the run scores
dearmeyer beats it out you can see marty
foster appeared to get set to make the
out call and then at the last split
second changed his mind fortunately for
the raise the call went their way that's
as close as it can get ooh
and we're going to see how he's out
and here's guerrero
and a drive hit to left field and deep
and over the head of meadows
biggio around third on his way home will
come in to score on an rbi double by
guerrero and the blue jays have tied it
well another good at bat for vladi
that'll extend his hit straight to seven
straight he's been on base both times
he's come to the plate against them and
with one down here in a tie game top of
the fourth he'll face the dh today
travis shaw
strike three call
shaw is out number two strikeout number
six altitudes a little cooler up there
danny jansen
two to chance it he strikes him out
fastball up 95 right there and he
strikes out the side 2-0 pitch to
wendell
a ground ball will sneak
past first and it's second a great play
made by bisho onto guerrero to get the
out
well it looked like it might get through
with a right field but biggio ranging to
his left makes a terrific play for the
second out williams up here trying to
keep the inning going
up the right side that's got some carry
will it stay fair that's a home run hit
the screening along the foul pole
down the right side and adamus
belting his third home run of the year
gives the raise a 3-1 lead
17 straight
and strike three bottom of the zone
all fastballs in that sequence and he
gets bigger looking eight strikeouts on
the day one more out to get lourdes
curry out
or on wednesday rather keep forgetting
this is monday feels like a sunday fly
ball to left field and gone
guriel getting just enough and he takes
snell out to make it a one-run game
curiel makes it a one-run game right
upstairs and he gets enough of it to
knock it out of the ballpark travis
shaw's popped up and he struck out
and the ground ball backhand stop oh
what a play on both ends adamus and
short and joy on the pickup short hop
backhand pickup by joy after adamus made
that great stop
it's first and second two down for
randall gretchen
a swing and a well hit ball down the
left field line it's gone
gretchick with a three-run homer and the
blue jays have taken a 5-3 lead
troy at second
sugo at first
ground ball right side backhanded
by guerrero jr and a wide throw to first
they got the out at second arona is
going to score
to make it a one-run game
the batter wouldn't the blue jays love a
little insurance here in the top of the
knife
lines it to right field and that'll get
down and get into the corner
espinal will come into score biggio on
his way to second with an rbi double it
is six to four and a huge run here in
the ninth inning so they are an out away
and a weak ground ball to the right side
romano's got a cover
and he gets there in time and the blue
jays will win it